[موسيقى
] ولدينا هذه المساحة الرائعة على السطح
والتي من الواضح أنها تطل مباشرة على
ساحة أنفسنا والقبة وهي في
الهواء الطلق ويمكننا سماع كل
ما يدور حولنا ورؤية كل
العروض الضوئية وكل شيء آخر
، وبالتالي فإن مزيج اليوبيل هو قليل من
جوهرة مخفية في معرض دبي إكسبو حتى الآن ،
نحن في الطابق العاشر من المركز الإعلامي للمعرض ،
لذا تصعد المصعد ،
تدخل الممر وتخرج
وستحصل على هذا المنظر الجميل وأنت
تعلم أنه مذهل هنا  وبعد ذلك
عندما تنطفئ الأضواء في المساء ،
تضيء جميع العروض الضوئية وتبدأ
الموسيقى في القبة
وهو مكان رائع للتواجد هنا ،
نعم ، عندما يستيقظ الضيوف هنا ومن
الواضح أنهم يخرجون مباشرة  يصلون
إلى الجو في الهواء الطلق
ويحصلون على هذا العامل المبهر
خاصة في وقت المساء عندما تكون
جميع الأضواء مضاءة والعروض على
[موسيقى]
نعم ، لذا لدينا قائمة الكوكتيل المميزة لدينا في
الأساطير لدينا
قائمة كاملة ملهمة  d من خلال
معارض الماضي ،
لذلك لدينا آيتشي
من اليابان المستوحى من
المعرض الياباني الذي يحتوي على
بيرة زنجبيل فودكا أوميشو وعشب الليمون ويتم
تقديمها في وعاء أرز ومع بعض
عيدان تناول الطعام على الجانب حتى تتمكن من
تناول الزينة بعد ذلك  حسنًا ،
نعم ، لدينا أيضًا معرض لندن الذي
يعد من المعرض أحد أوائل المعارض
التي تحتوي على ريحان بولدوج جين ريكارد ونقدمها
مع
فقاعة دخان في الأعلى من مكبر النكهة الخاص بنا
، ولذا فهي تبدو رائعة حقًا
على  عرض
[الموسيقى]
لدينا أيضًا كوكتيل ميلانو من
ميلانو في إيطاليا بشكل واضح وهذا
تطور على الزنجروني الكلاسيكي لدينا
كامباري جينزانو روسو ونضيف
فرانجليكو إلى ذلك أيضًا
[موسيقى]
لذا بالنسبة إلى معرض دبي إكسبو نحن '  لقد
ابتكرنا كوكتيلًا مميزًا يُدعى
زهرة اليوبيل ويتم تقديمه مع
الفودكا وبعض الفراولة وبعض
الجير ونقوم بقليل من غبار الذهب على
القمة أيضًا للاحتفال
بالذكرى الخمسين لتأسيس دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة وللتوافق
مع الحقيقة  أننا في
المعرض وهو عام اليوبيل أيضًا
[موسيقى] ،
لذا فإن جميع التوقيعات مشهورة جدًا
وأنت تعلم أنه تم إنشاؤها بواسطة
مدير البار الرائع لدينا
وهو أه موهوب جدًا
ولديه كل هذه المزيجات  التقنيات
لذلك هناك القليل من العرض بالإضافة
إلى المشروب الذي تحصل عليه قليلاً من العرض
وبالطبع نحن في أعظم
عرض في العالم أيضًا ، لذا
فإن كل العلاقات بشكل جيد للغاية